Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Emma Gon
Un banquero en Londres envía
la últimainformación accionaria
a sus colegas en Hong Kong
en menos de un segundo.
Con un solo clic,
un cliente en Nueva York
compra un aparato
hecho en Beijing,
que es transportado a través
del océano en cuestión de días
por avión de carga o
buque portacontenedores.
La velocidad y el volumen en
los que bienes e información
se mueven a través del mundo de hoy
no tiene precedentes en la historia.
Pero el intercambio global es
más antiguo de lo que creemos,
se remonta a más de 2000 años
en un tramo de más de 8000 km
conocida como la Ruta de la Seda.
La Ruta de la Seda no era
en realidad un solo camino,
sino una red de múltiples rutas
que surgieron gradualmente
a lo largo de siglos,
conectando a diversos
asentamientos entre sí
hebra por hebra.
Las primeras civilizaciones
agrícolas estuvieron aisladas
en los valles fértiles de ríos,
y la geografía circundante y el miedo a
lo desconocido, les impedía viajar.
Pero a medida que crecían,
se encontraron con que los áridos
desiertos y los pasos en sus fronteras
estaban habitados, no por
los demonios del folclore,
sino por tribus nómadas a caballo.
Los escitas, que iban
desde Hungría a Mongolia,
habían entrado en contacto
con las civilizaciones de
Grecia, Egipto, India y China.
Estos encuentros eran a
menudo menos que pacíficos.
Pero incluso a través de
las incursiones y la guerra,
y del comercio y la protección
de los comerciantes viajeros
a cambio de un pago,
los nómadas comenzaron a propagar
bienes, ideas y tecnologías
entre culturas que
no tenían contacto directo.
Uno de los hilos más importantes
de esta red creciente
fue el Camino Real Persa,
terminado por Darío I
en el siglo V a.C.
Con una extensión de más de 3000 km,
del río Tigris hasta el mar Egeo,
sus puntos de relevo permitían
a bienes y mensajes
viajar en casi 1/10 del tiempo del
que le tomaría a un viajero individual.
Con la conquista de
Alejandro Magno de Persia,
y la expansión hacia Asia Central a través
de la captura de ciudades como Samarcanda,
y el establecimiento de otras
nuevas como Alejandría Escate,
la red de cultura y comercio
egipcio, persa, griego e indio
se extendió más al oriente
como nunca antes,
sentando las bases de un puente
entre China y Occidente.
Esto se cumplió en el siglo II a.C.,
cuando un embajador
llamado Zhang Qian,
fue enviado a negociar con
los nómadas en el occidente,
y regresó al emperador
Han con cuentos de
civilizaciones sofisticadas,
el comercio próspero
y mercancías exóticas fueron más allá
de las fronteras occidentales.
Embajadores y comerciantes
fueron enviados hacia
Persia e India para comerciar seda
y jade por caballos y el algodón,
junto con ejércitos
para asegurar su paso.
Las rutas orientales y occidentales
gradualmente se unieron entre sí
en un sistema integrado
que abarcaba Eurasia,
permitiendo intercambio
cultural y comercial
más lejos que nunca.
Productos chinos
hicieron su camino a Roma,
ocasionando una salida de oro,
que llevó a la prohibición de la seda,
mientras que la cristalería romana
era muy apreciada en China.
Las expediciones militares
en Asia Central
también vieron encuentros
entre soldados chinos y romanos.
Posiblemente incluso la transmisión
de tecnología de la ballesta
al mundo occidental.
La demanda de bienes
exóticos y extranjeros
y las utilidades que trajeron,
mantuvo las hebras de
la Ruta de la Seda intactas,
aun cuando el Imperio
Romano se desintegró
y las dinastías chinas
florecieron y decayeron.
Incluso las hordas mongolas,
conocidos por el pillaje y el saqueo,
protegían activamente las rutas
comerciales, en lugar de destruirlas.
Pero junto con las materias primas,
estas rutas también permitieron
el movimiento de las tradiciones, las
innovaciones, las ideologías y los idiomas.
Originario de la India, el budismo
emigró a China y Japón
para convertirse en
la religión dominante allí.
El Islam se extendió por
la Península Arábiga en el sur de Asia,
mezclado con las creencias nativas
y dando lugar a nuevas religiones,
como el sijismo.
Y la pólvora hizo su camino
desde China a Oriente Medio
para forjar el futuro de los imperios
otomano, safávida y mongol.
En cierto modo, el éxito de la Ruta
de la Seda condujo a su propio colapso
al llegar a Europa las nuevas tecnologías
marítimas, como la brújula,
con lo que las largas rutas
terrestres se volvieron obsoletas.
Mientras tanto, el colapso
del gobierno mongol
fue seguido por la retirada de
China del comercio internacional.
Pero a pesar de que las antiguas
rutas y redes no duraron,
habían cambiado
el mundo para siempre
y no había vuelta atrás.
Los europeos buscando
nuevas rutas marítimas
a las riquezas que sabían que
les esperaban en Asia Oriental
llevaron a la Era de la Exploración
y la expansión hacia
África y las Américas.
Hoy en día, la interconexión global da
forma a nuestras vidas como nunca antes.
Compradores canadienses compran
camisetas hechas en Bangladesh,
el público japonés ve programas
de la televisión británica,
y los tunecinos utilizan software
estadounidense para lanzar una revolución.
El impacto de la globalización sobre
la cultura y la economía es indiscutible.
Pero cualesquiera que sean
sus ventajas e inconvenientes,
está lejos de ser
un fenómeno nuevo.
Y a pesar de que las montañas,
los desiertos y los océanos
una vez nos separaron,
ahora son eludidos mediante
vehículos supersónicos,
cables de comunicación
intercontinentales,
y señales que se irradian
a través del espacio
en lugar de las caravanas
que viajan por meses,
nada de esto hubiera sido posible
sin las culturas pioneras
cuyos esfuerzos crearon
la Ruta de la Seda:
primera red mundial
de la historia.